serrez ses enfants un peu plus fort ce
matin avant de les laisser à l'école des
parents toujours secoués au lendemain du
drame tout le monde se connaisse c'est
tout le quartier de Sainte-Rose qui
ressent l'absence des enfants disparus
raconte Marianne Michaud le petit garçon
qui est décédé je le croisais à tous les
matins quand je marchais par les porter
mes enfants à l'école on se dit allô il
disait toujours aller à mon petit garçon
on était tout le temps son repas pour
pas qu'il soit en retard à l'école ce
matin
c'est vraiment difficile
après avoir remorqué l'autobus dans la
nuit le périmètre de sécurité a été
retiré ce matin permettant aux familles
et aux proches d'aller voir ce qui reste
de la garderie mais surtout de se
recueillir
sur place le fils de Gabriel la flamme
fréquentait la garderie il tenait à
revenir pour soutenir les familles
endeuilly lui qui peut trop facilement
se mettre à leur place si on le laisse
juste 5 minutes de plus à la maison puis
je remercie de l'avoir laissé jouer 5
minutes de plus parce que
François Legault est venu apporter son
soutien à la propriétaire et à la
directrice de la garderie
et saluer le courage des pères qui sont
intervenus pour maîtriser le chauffage
et sauver des enfants pour eux la scène
est encore vivante
les voix des enfants dans la tête
c'est très lourd les voix qu'on a pas pu
aider les enfants qui sont décédés on a
partagé les rôles réellement on faisait
on maîtrise on cherche on revient pour
maîtriser on recherche et à je parle
avec moi et que tout le soir est-ce que
tu es arrivé à dormir est-ce que tu as
pu tu as pu passer c'est ça c'est une
amitié qui a été créée entre nous
réellement François Legault presse tous
ceux qui en ont besoin d'aller chercher
de l'aide même les enfants qui ont vu ça
les employés qui ont vu ça probablement
c'est des images qui vont garder dans
leur tête toute leur vie donc accepter
la psychologie
une classe politique qui dans un
rarement d'unité mais la partisanerie de
côté alors c'est important de démontrer
notre solidarité
de prier pour les victimes et d'être là
pour les proches les parents il y aura
des questions qu'on devrait se poser
comme société dans les prochains jours
dans les prochaines semaines pour
essayer de commencer à comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et on aura besoin de temps
qu'on aura besoin d'entraide pour
pour que on puisse ensuite
trouver une paix
en soirée c'était au tour de
juillet à la chandelle à la mémoire des
victimes je peux pas imaginer ce que les
familles
sont en train de vivre ce soir ni la
Valois
sont en train d'être là les uns pour les
autres et l'appui que tout le monde veut
et va donner les uns aux autres dans les
dans les jours les mois les années à
venir
il faut toujours être présent difficile
de trouver les mots devant un tel drame
toujours inexplicable mais dans la
communauté depuis hier c'est le besoin
de se rassembler qui prime ici
j'accoudrer Charbonneau Radio-Canada